All right, so the phone ain't ringing now what first of all if it's been 24 hours 12 hours
Two days three days even four days and you're watching this video and going. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh
Oh my gosh, stop turn off the video and wait a little longer
Okay, but if it's been ten days or let's say say eight to ten days and nothing's happening. You're not getting any leads then
Yeah, we let's dig in let's figure out what's going on
So the first thing that we want to do is we got to figure out we got to diagnose the problem
Okay, we're gonna figure out what is it that we're not getting? Okay, obviously, we're not getting leads
But let's go back a little bit further. Let's see if it's deeper than that. Are we not getting leads? Okay, great
So but are we getting clicks?
Okay, so we're getting clicks but not leads so we can kind of look there. Are we getting impressions?
Okay, so we're getting impressions, but not clicks
So maybe it's there, you know, and we just start digging in layer by layer by layer
But here is the key and this is very similar to when you're not closing deals
You always want to look at the step or steps prior because that's where the issue is
Okay, and so here's what you need to look at
Okay
If you are not getting and let me see if I can say this correctly if I if I don't say it correctly
I will resay it and I'll tell you but I might mess this up
Okay, but it just just hear me out. So if you are not getting leads
But you're getting clicks. It's usually an issue with your landing page because think about it. People are clicking on your ads
They're going to your page, but you're not converting them into calls. So it's usually a landing page issue. Okay now if you are getting
impressions
But you're not getting clicks
It's usually an issue with your ad, right? Google is showing it to people they're putting it in front of people's faces
That's the impressions but your ad copy is not grabbing them. And so that's why they're not
Clicking on it. Okay, and so you just need to figure out like what is the issue?
Because ultimately if we're not getting phone calls that is that's a problem
That's that's what we need to figure out
We want to go deeper and want to figure out what part of this we're actually
Making a mistake. Okay, so that's number one is we're gonna diagnose where the issue is step two after you've diagnosed
What part? Okay. Well, I'm getting impressions, but I'm not getting clicks or I'm getting clicks
But I'm not getting calls
What I want you to do is I want you to go and watch
The video prior the video prior to this or the two prior to this or whatever video you need to watch that talks about
That specific topic. So if you're having an issue with
The landing page because you're getting clicks, but you're not getting calls
You're gonna want to go and watch the module that talks about
That building the landing page you're gonna talk. It's called money love speed
That's the module you're gonna want to watch the infamous one pager
Okay, if you're having a problem with some other area go watch that video
So I want you to go and watch that video
Whatever one it is and figure out is it something that you skipped whether on accident or on purpose because most often what I found
Is that it's not because what we trained isn't working
It's because you did something incorrect
Maybe you set up the landing page and you thought you did everything correctly
But you look at it and the phone number is nowhere to be found
You had all the intention of the world of putting the phone number on there
But it's just nowhere to be found or maybe it's right there, but it's not clickable or maybe it's clickable
But it's not underlined. It's not highlighted and so no one's clicking on it. Maybe you didn't put the form
Maybe the four like there's so many different variables
I want you to go and rewatch that specific video that pertains to that step or covers that step and make sure you're doing it
Exactly how it's trained in that video
Okay, because until you do that we're not gonna be able to know and I'm telling you most often 99% of the time
You're gonna figure out what you're doing wrong. You're gonna go. Let's say let's say you're getting impressions, but you're not getting clicks
You're gonna go look at your ad copy and you're gonna go. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. I put I spelled the city wrong
I put Queen Creek and I spelled it. I spelled Creek wrong
I added an E and people are seeing it and they like oh my gosh, who's this incompetent business, right?
So go first of all step one diagnosed step two go watch the video
That talks about and trains on the part that you're messing up. Okay based on your diagnosis step three
I'm gonna ask you to go into the Facebook community and
Search the group okay
I'm gonna have you search the group and look for conversations related to what you're having an issue with
So if you're having an issue with your landing page
I want you to go into this search bar at the very top corner a little magnifying glass and type click on it and type
landing page one pager
Whatever
Weebly site or any keyword that you think people would type in when they're referring to
The page that we eventually throw away the landing page that we use and then we eventually throw away and I want you to search for
conversations around that and the reason I'm gonna direct you here instead of immediately just reaching out to fix it Felix or reaching
Out to me or reaching out to somebody else is because guys I'm trying to turn you into entrepreneurs
I'm trying to see how many millionaires I can create in this group and you just messaging me and me spoon-feeding you the answer
First of all, it's not it doesn't work like mathematically. I don't have the time but number two. It's not teaching you anything
Okay, I want you to be a problem solver. I want you to be able to go. Okay
I diagnosed the issue. I
Went and watched the video and now I'm gonna go search the group and search these conversations to see that see if I can figure
It out on my own because what happens when you have this problem? It's 2 a.m. In the morning and everybody's asleep
Okay, all right. You don't have the option to reach out to people
Okay, I want you to be a problem solver. And so I'm first after you've diagnosed it after you've watched the video
I want you to go and I want you to search the group and look for threads look for
Conversations about the thing that you're struggling with whether it's the ad copy whether it's the one pager whether it's
Setting up the ad properly get a location or whatever
You've diagnosed as the issue number four the fourth thing that I want you to do is if you go in and you've done all
These things you've diagnosed it. You've watched the video. You've searched the group. You've looked at the conversation
You've responded to it and you're still stuck
Go and make a post go and make a post. It says hey guys, I
Have X amount of clicks and no leads and I've done this this this and this and I'm just not figuring this out
Could somebody give me some insight and you're free to tag fix it Felix. Okay, you're free to tag me as well
I'm just gonna be honest. I'll get to it as fast as I can but I am trying my best to use my time the best
The best to benefit everybody. Okay, so tagging fix that Felix is gonna be your best option
But go and make a post and be very thorough be very specific about it and ask people for help say hey
Here's what's going on. I've done this this isn't this and I still can't figure it out
Is there anybody that can help me and maybe what you can do is you can look and go?
There's some of those threads some of those comments I looked at that was Jeff, you know Jeff was having that issue
So maybe you go and you can tag Jeff, you know, yeah after you post it at Jeff
Hey Jeff, I noticed you were having some similar issues. You have any insight on this
Use your head and go and post. I'm telling you if you do those four steps and
You again, this is I just should even go without saying but I'm gonna say it make sure that this isn't you just completely didn't skip
Module one where I said don't go into these niches look out for this, you know, look out for that, etc
Then you are going to figure this out some other things to take into account and they're easier to forget during the summer
Which it's summer right now and I'm filming this in the winter. It's really easy is I also want you to think about the winter
I want you to think about the the the weather right now
I know in Australia and some other places winter is different different time of the year
But think about it, right use your head go look at the forecast
You're running concrete ads and it's December and and you're in Minneapolis
Okay, first of all, you should probably shouldn't be in Minneapolis
But let's say you are let's say for some weird reason that the due diligence works and it's a low-hanging fruit layup
Guys who's searching for concrete who's even thinking about putting in concrete during Christmas?
Nobody wants to go spend money on concrete during Christmas
That's something you spend for most homeowners after they get their tax returns back when it's spring cleanup when people are getting back into
Backyards and cleaning up the yard and do all those things use your head go look at the last 10 days weather
Could that be affecting it? Is there a hurt? Are you in Florida and there's a damn hurricane? Okay
Are you in Arkansas and there has been a tornado look at these different factors and also this is something to consider
And I guess I I almost skip over this because it just makes sense in my head
But don't look okay
If this was in your city is there something that's happening in your city that there's probably not that many people searching that weekend
Is it the Ironman that weekend go and use your head and look at those things?
But if you use your head you've done the the the module one correctly you've picked the perfect niche
You've you've found a layup and you've done those four things guys. We're gonna figure this out
I promise you there's always a solution and we will figure this out
That's it